I loved you guys that this film is very
different to see you guys and girls like
this Xander with an X and Sandra yeah
Sandra's good Sandra Sanders good - what
was it like taking on a cure well a
couple like this that are a little bit
disturbing look I mean yeah I mean I
think Sarah is known for doing a wide
range of roles but yeah I think I
definitely have done like a lot of kind
of comedies and lighter things so I
found it especially interesting to get
the chance to do something like this and
that's where it was really fun to work
with the director like John Crowley
where you knew that if he'd hired you he
kind of believed in you so you know I
was it tough to do that one scene I
don't want to ruin it I want to talk
about it but that one scene with Oakes
when you have that moment it was hard I
mean we were kind of talking about that
earlier where you know if you're you
really do kind of take the work home
with you whatever you're doing if you're
doing you know a comedy you're thinking
oh yeah that's a that's a good idea it's
funny I'll try that tomorrow I can't
wait to see that you know person I
worked with Today Tomorrow to work on
that funny scene but something like this
where it's darker you just kind of go
home it's not as if you feel a weight
lifted or even necessarily had a good
day at work you've kind of had a day
where you were kind of being physical
with this you know kind of helpless kid
but yeah you would just hope yeah remind
yourself about know what your goals are
and what the finished product hopefully
will look like what was the reaction for
both of you to watch this film because
you're right it is there where I've seen
oh you have not oh really and why is
that just hasn't it just hasn't happened
but yeah at the time when we could have
seen and I've been in Atlanta and I've
been in I've been here well we're gonna
get to see it tomorrow yeah yeah I mean
you're you're known for putting on
different types of outfits like Marcia
Clark into this character did you have
fun with it a little bit
yeah it's extremely fun I mean it was a
I don't wear clothing like that and it's
a little no really were exposing them a
little more exposing than I generally
like that to but it was it was
challenging but it was also what I
wanted to do right by Donna Tartt is
really care about and I guess that would
be the great unknown thing it's like
what will she make of it and what will
you know was it right was it not and
I'll never know but that was that was
sort of my guiding the compass I was
most interested in in being guided by
was going back to the book and being
reminded of the moments before or that
are some of the scenes that are not in
the movie that are in the book yeah so
yeah I'm excited for you guys I'll see
you guys during the red carpet okay